what up space fam golden here for anime
uproar and i'm back at it to discuss the
latest developments in the dragon ball
super story
in the last review a bunch of you said
you'd like to keep seeing dragon ball
super on this channel so to keep the
reviews coming make sure to turn that
like button blue
like vegeta's hair and to share this
video with your cultured dragon ball
friends
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future dragon ball
videos
as you wait for the next dragon ball
super chapter to drop check out our
playlist of dragon ball videos
link in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all this chapter is called edge of
defeat and oh man does it
ever describe this chapter perfectly we
know that dragon ball has never shied
away
from having villains absolutely wreck
our main characters and their main
characters have even been killed in the
past
and then brought back of course but the
point is anything could happen in dragon
ball
here moro is a different kind of villain
compared to many that we've seen in
dragon ball
super in the sense that he's a huge
threat who seems to be one-sidedly
wrecking our guys at this point
early on in this chapter morrow explains
that 7-3's power
has been added to his own after he ate
him in a very bizarre way
vegeta is not out for the count yet and
tries to tear him apart again
using his new four spirit fish and
powers
but he can't even land a hit now morrow
even mentions that the technique
requires vegeta to inflict damage
and moro is not going to let him do that
moral wastes no time
explaining how bad the situation is he
explains that his own power is back home
so it won't run
out in 30 minutes as was the case for
7-3
plus he's gained 7 3's ability to copy
other people's powers
he even copies vegeta's abilities he
then goes on to use vegeta's epic big
bang attack
moro hits vegeta with it and vegeta
looks down for the count
taken down by his own attack moore even
insults one vegeta's greatest attacks
so the prince of saiyans who's always
been a prideful dude and he was on cloud
9 just a few moments ago
he has now been completely embarrassed
and disrespected this is a crazy
twist at this point and it's making
things very interesting
morrow is the real deal not only is he
strong this goat man can now potentially
use all of our main characters as moves
against them
if he copies them imagine if someone was
stronger than you and could use all of
your moves
plus others it's truly seeming like a
hopeless situation at this point and i
like it from a storytelling perspective
the more opian opponent
is the more satisfying it usually is
when our main characters defeat him and
now things are seeming hopeless af and
as a result
i'm extremely curious and excited to see
how they'll get out of this one
piccolo then points out even worse news
since morrow can now use all of vegeta's
moves
he can use force spirit fission meaning
that vegito and gogeta
are not gonna be viable options even if
they are pushed to their limits
i mentioned last chapter that an enemy
could come around with this ability
and here we are a chapter later and
already that scenario is being put into
play
the possibility of using fusion to win
as a last resort
no longer seems to be on the table we
jump to bulma and others
as they follow the events from a
relatively safe distance
for now at least then they offers to go
so that he can help restore people's
energy he's totally down to sacrifice
his life
but he can't as the earth's guardian sit
by and do nothing
respect for him he has the mindset and
courage of a real hero
even if he's not one of the stronger
characters in the series
at the same time we see krillin who has
some senzu beans and he's trying to get
there too
in time so that he can help heal his
friends clearly we got back up coming so
all hope is not
lost even though things are not looking
great right now piccolo and gohan attack
together and i was worried that they'd
just get wiped out immediately
but we do see some cool combos piccolo
holds moro
in place by his legs gohan seemingly
traps him with an energy ring and then
super saiyan blue goku appears with a
warp kamehameha i love the teamwork
and the combos and how warp command may
have made an appearance
the result is that moro loses an arm
finally it appears like our dudes can
land some hits do some damage and
then bam next second morrow with a
delighted smile on his face regenerates
his arm
and stabs goku right through the chest
that's some serious brutal damage right
there
goku has that look in his eyes like his
life has all but drained out of him
completely moro explains that all the
abilities 7-3 copied
are now his forever with no time limits
wow not only was he kicking butt
but he was even hiding something like
that up his sleeve this dude can
regenerate
doesn't have a bead of sweat on him his
strong af can learn any move potentially
and all of our guys are dropping like
flies even goku who's usually the guy
that makes everyone feel safe and like
things will work out
all our guys have going for them is that
moro doesn't want them to die
yet since he wants to savor them as his
meals i gotta say
i'm a fan of moro as a villain he's
strong tricky and strategic
he's the kind of guy to have backup
plans and to hold back some of the aces
up his sleeves
definitely a worthy opponent gohan tries
to do something and fails miserably
piccolo is told by dende that help is on
the way
but morrow having the meccan powers now
picks up the message
what does he do he creates a barrier so
nobody can come through
he's not taking any chances he's careful
and doesn't want to give goku
or vegeta another chance to take him on
at full power both dende and krillin
are kept from helping and everyone is
kept from escaping
morrow proceeds to flex on everyone he
takes care of the androids without even
turning around
piccolo admirably prepares to sacrifice
his life along with the others
in the barrier since they're gonna die
anyways so that they could at least
take morrow with them he prepares to
unleash the biggest
ki blasts he can in the form of
self-destruction but again
moro gets piccolo with piccolo's own
move just like when he got vegeta with
big bang attack
he gets piccolo just like piccolo got
raditz ages ago
there are some great nods to previous
dragon ball sagas and moments
throughout this chapter and i really
appreciate that about this one
special beam canon took out raditz and
goku back in the day
and so piccolo is clearly on the verge
of death and goku is too with his own
chest whole
just as jock was the only one left to
stand against moro the beast
dende makes it through the barrier an
angel has appeared creating a hole in
the barrier
based on the staff and the arm behind
his back it appears to be whis
although we can't know for sure because
the face is purposely not shown
jocko starts to fire at moro who plans
to kill the patrol officer
immediately since he's so weak and not
even worth eating but another shot comes
off at the same time and unexpectedly
this one is enough to annoy moro then we
see that agent merus himself has
appeared and he imbued his own energy
into the shot so that it would be all
the stronger
more looks angered knowing that there's
more to merus
than just being a galactic patrol
officer and
mero smiles so we got a complete 180
here
we went from morrow flexing on everybody
to merus showing
up then they getting in to heal the
others and moro being irritated
meros as an angel is not supposed to
interfere but clearly he is going to
and it seemed to me that whis might be
present because of the staff and the way
whis holds one hand behind his back
that's not weird for an angel to do but
we definitely haven't seen meros do it
as much as wheeze
if it was whis and not mero's pre-closed
transformation then that suggests that
whis is on board with the plan
and meros is not just acting alone even
though merus isn't supposed to interfere
as an angel we did see whis reverse time
before
and thereby save the earth from frieza
so clearly the angels won't necessarily
get punished right away like in death
note where the shinigami will die
if they interfere to save a human life
perhaps angels can get away with aiding
people a bit
but they can't just take out their
opponents for them
my thought process is that we'll get a
situation similar to last time where an
angel will help
but our main guys will have to finish it
off merus will buy
time until our fighters can somehow heal
enough
and then they're going to get a chance
at redemption and even though he's got
a hole in his chest i find it hard to
believe that we won't see
mastered ultra instinct from goku in
this arc
i think he will somehow get healed
enough to use mastered ultra instinct
since at some point
he's gonna have to be able to use that
form again especially now that the enemy
is this strong
i'm just imagining trains think the
vegito
with four spirit fission being too fast
for moro
to use four spirit fishing back on him
but that's probably overkill for this
arc i am curious though to see how
vegeta might catch up to mastered ultra
instinct 2. the bottom line is things
are getting very interesting
moro has proven to be a great villain
who's going to push our guys to their
limits and beyond
so we can look forward to crazy
power-ups as this arc progresses
and that's something i always enjoy let
me know your thoughts on this chapter
and what you expect to see happening
next in the comments below
i am personally super excited to see
more of what an
angel can be capable of in a fight i
feel like we're definitely in
store for some mind-blowing
game-changing events in the chapters to
come and that is it for this chapter
review
if you enjoy seeing these dragon ball
super chat reviews and want to keep them
coming
make sure to smash that like button turn
it blue like vegeta's hair
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future dragon ball
videos
as you wait for the next dragon ball
super chapter to drop
check out our playlist of dragon ball
videos links in the description
lastly the youtube ad rates have dropped
big time so the support we're getting
from our anime outpour patrons
is very appreciated a very special thank
you goes for patrons over on patreon who
help us survive these youtube issues and
who help make videos like this one
possible
first and foremost i want to thank are
the one-tier patrons the ones who stand
atop
all clans stephen and grotta alola and
atem the world steelers acquire respect
pate hepa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez thomas
jones
ken mono michael hyde and jaden the
vector controller
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings algis anatoly
kazotsky
angel cruz cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci alicia actor jessica kayla font
hinokami and water bonnie parks
zodiar12 rathu and de aura kraken arels
and deadly saint thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime for a link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you